for years the libs told conservatives
that if we don't like the way that they
censor us on big tech platforms that we
should build our own build your own
twitter build your own facebook build
your own google
the suggestion is absurd
maybe in the very earliest days of
social media there was room for
competition remember myspace live
journal xanga friendster lots of other
sites those days are over they've been
over for a long time eventually a
handful of platforms reached a critical
mass and ensconced themselves in power
and they formed cozy relationships with
the federal government and they
exploited legal liability protections
and they even outright defrauded the
user base that gave them the critical
mass in the first place with the
understanding that they would be able to
see and post whatever they wanted to
then the big tech companies pulled the
rug out it is simply not possible to
build our own twitter it hasn't been for
years and leftists know it which is why
they keep making the suggestion
conservatives could try to wield the
government to bring these massive
corporations into line but that's very
difficult if not impossible
and lots of conservatives don't have the
stomach for it and even those of us who
do have the stomach for it don't have
any real political power in a system
dominated almost entirely by the left
but it turns out there's a third option
beyond build your own twitter and break
twitter
and that is
buy twitter
buy twitter which is what elon musk is
apparently willing to do spending more
than 41
billion dollars right now on offer and
why is he doing it
my
strong intuitive sense is that uh having
a public platform that is maximally
trusted
um and and and and
broadly inclusive
um
is extremely important
to the future of civilization but you've
described yourself i don't care about
the economics at all
okay that's that's cool to hear bingo
republics govern through speech in the
public square
twitter makes up a huge portion of the
public square
and twitter is keeping lots of americans
out of the public square including
really prominent ones including donald
trump right including the duly elected
sitting president when they took him out
which means as a practical matter that
right now we are no longer living in a
functioning republic
so elon musk is going to mount a hostile
takeover to take it back and what
happens if that takeover attempt doesn't
work
okay so so you don't like to lose if in
this case you are not successful in you
know the board
does not accept your offer you've said
you won't go higher is there a plan b
there is
i i think we i think we would like to
hear a little bit about plan b
for it for another time i think
another time yeah all right
i love it so much
i don't think i'm going to tell you my
plan b elon of course could have
anything up his sleeve he's currently
got more than nine percent of the
company up his sleeve meaning that he
could sell all of it and tank the stock
or he might have something even more
creative planned or or it might all just
be a giant troll
to expose the hideous corruption at
twitter and throughout silicon valley
either way
it is the most hopeful moment for
conservatives that we have had in
politics since election night 2016. i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from ai survivor
2020 who says wow the show hasn't even
started yet and youtube already has a
warning underneath this video guess they
all fear the raw power of nostradamus i
think they probably do i actually sort
of like it when when youtube puts that
banner the cdc go listen to dr fauci do
whatever we tell you to do beneath my
videos even even before they begin or
when they've only been out for an hour
because that's an advertisement to
people to say hey come here to learn
about what's actually going on with
covid today
hey
head on over to the michael knowles show
he's going to tell you stuff that we
don't want you to know so i love it
bring it on youtube i really really
appreciate that i i like being able to
do things for myself to research these
questions myself to figure out things on
my own i even like being able to
maintain my automobile on my own which
is why you got to check out rockauto
right now head to rockauto.com write
knolls in their how did you hear about
us box so they know that we sent you i
bet that the value of your car or your
minivan or your pickup or whatever you
drive probably appreciated significantly
last year that's what we're seeing all
around the country so take care of your
automotive investment and keep more of
your money by buying the auto parts that
you need to maintain and repair your
vehicle at rockauto.com they've got all
the parts and tools that you're going to
need including stuff that you would
imagine is only available at the
dealerships i'm even thinking of the
little you know the little fan that
cools your derriere and some of the cool
hip modern cars rockauto.com has it
they've got everything they've got all
the trusted name brands that you want
the catalog is super easy to use they
even give you installation tips which is
helpful for people such as myself who
are not necessarily pros same price for
pros and do-it-yourselfers go to
rockauto.com right now get all those
auto parts you need write nulls can or w
l e s in there how did you hear about
xbox so they know that we sent you go
check out rock auto today
twitter
twitter is so upset
not twitter users twitter users love the
potential elon takeover but i'm talking
about the staff of twitter i'm talking
about the leadership over at twitter
they are so just to just
to be sure that we're not here knocking
down straw men that were not here stuck
in our own echo chamber i'm really
pleased to be joined right now by the
staff and leadership over at twitter
headquarters uh hey guys what what
thank you one for being here and two
what is your reaction to the news that
elon musk might be taking over twitter
that's pretty articulate that's about as
articulate as i thought it was going to
be no
no they're they are really
really upset right now and they're upset
because they're going to lose a lot of
political power
this is not about the financials at all
the
the stock soared when elon musk
announced that he had bought some of it
so it's not about the financials it's
about the the real value of twitter
which is that
twitter allows you to control discourse
in america by the way twitter's the
smallest of the big tech platforms by
far it doesn't have a particularly large
user base facebook for instance has a
much much larger user base than twitter
and google controls way more information
really than either of them
but twitter sets the news cycle
because of the people who are on twitter
you've got a ton of journalists you've
got a ton of those blue checks who have
a lot of influence and so if you can
control the narrative on twitter in many
ways you're controlling the news cycle
that's that's the reason that elon's
going in there to buy it right now i
suspect that's at least why people are
excited that he's going to do that
there's a lot
of
powerful entrenched interests who want
to make sure that that doesn't happen
one of the wildest examples was saudi
arabia
so in response to elon musk's potential
takeover
saudi arabia has just come out and said
listen the kingdom has a lot of stock in
twitter and we don't think that the
price that elon is offering which is
at a huge premium by the way over what
the stock is actually worth today he's
offering something like 54 dollars per
share it's way up it's over 50
over what the price was when elon bought
into twitter and to 38 over what what
the price was
right before elon announced that he had
bought into twitter but the kingdom of
saudi arabia for whatever reason says no
we don't think this is high enough why
is that well elon musk asks the question
he says interesting two questions here
if i may how much of twitter does the
kingdom own directly and indirectly and
two what are the kingdom's views on
journalistic freedom of speech
and that second question's important
because we know that saudi arabia likes
to take a hacksaw to journalistic
freedom of speech
and notably in the case of jamal
khashoggi
who was not merely
just some independent journalist
shedding light on issues jamal khashoggi
did write for the washington post he
also was a saudi regime insider he also
was a spy for the regime he also was on
on the wrong side of political issues in
saudi arabia this this became a big
political football a few years ago but
the question is a good one from elon
musk what is it saudi arabia about
twitter that that is so valuable to you
saudi arabia just pumps money out of the
ground
some
the smallest big tech company doesn't
matter as a financial issue to saudi
arabia it matters as a political issue
to set the agenda and so frankly even if
the elon takeover doesn't work or even
if he backs out in the end the fact that
he's exposing all of this corruption
there is a service into itself unto
itself rather and you're seeing this
kind of
bare-knuckle politics
throughout the system the rnc has just
made an excellent announcement
so rare to say that about the rnc which
usually only does extremely stupid
things and clutches defeat from the jaws
of victory but the rnc made a great
announcement the rnc is going to pull
out of the
non-partisan commission on presidential
debates
that commission it sounds really nice
doesn't it
it's nonpartisan so they say
it's just a way that we can all come
together what do you oh you awful
republicans what are you you're afraid
of debate you refuse to work across the
aisle you're putting party before
country
no the
the commission on presidential debates
is a rigged game it has been for a long
time bob dole pointed this out in 2020
bob dole who is the 1996 republican
nominee for president bob dole major
force in republican politics for half a
century
dole came out and he said this is not
fair to trump because yes while
technically the nonpartisan commission
on presidential debates is half
democrats and half republicans dole said
no one on the commission supports trump
even the republicans on the commission
are those squishy republican types who
were effectively working for the
democrat campaign so it's just a totally
rigged system and we know this in all
the major presidential
years and for the past i don't know
20 years or so quarter century
in the in the big presidential debates
the debate moderators have have tried to
throw the debates for the democrat
certainly you saw this with chris
wallace just outright lying during the
the big debate between trump and biden
you saw this with candy crowley do you
remember that candy crowley during the
debate between mitt romney and barack
obama also lied on behalf of barack
obama contradicted mitt romney
dishonestly and through the entire
debate possibly through the election
probably wasn't that it probably wasn't
sufficient to actually throw the
election romney didn't run a great
campaign but it's a totally rigged game
and something that i think conservatives
have woken up to and this is a really
important rule i mentioned this the
other night on the backstage when we
were talking about the daily wire
business strategy
when the game is rigged
you have to break the rules
one rule that we've bought into for
years with men's clothing is that if you
want really nice sophisticated looking
clothing you're going to have to bathe
and sweat when you go outside well you
don't need to do that anymore with
mizzen in maine
right now head on over to
missonandmaine.com use promo code nolds
just the other day i was packing for a
trip down to the beach and i open up my
closet where does my eye go right to
goes right to one of my absolute
favorite polo shirts from misson and
maine what do i love so much about this
shirt one
number one it looks phenomenal the style
is just really crisp and clean and
sophisticated looking but two
i am of italian descent it means i have
a penchant for perspiring okay this is
not great with a lot of different shirt
companies missing in maine because it's
that performance athletic material with
that great classic style it means i
don't need to worry about sweating
through my shirt they've got all sorts
of stuff they've obviously got their
great oxford shirts they've got
you know dress shirts everything you can
skip the dry cleaner i really love those
performance polos in particular right
now
whether you're working from the golf
course or taking conference calls in the
courtyard we've got some really great
news right now if you go to mizmain.com
use promo code nulls you get 35 off any
regular price order of 125 bucks or more
that's 35 bucks off when you go to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n-dot-com use
promo code knowles go check out mizzen
and maine today
more great news for the right i ca we're
going to take the wins when we can get
them there's always so much bad news for
conservatives for the right for a
traditional way of life let's take the
big wins when we can get them ron
desantis down there in florida
has just signed a major abortion ban and
not only that but you know they say
flattery will get you nowhere flat
that's not necessarily true in politics
ron desantis as he's signing this major
abortion ban
cites daily wire as one of the
inspirations
you see how
that type of mindset has led to uh
things that really shocked the
conscience in our society we just saw
this terrible scandal in washington dc
oh yeah do we
where is mary margaret here from the
daily wire
there's mary margaret she did this great
uh expose
they found
all these remains
of babies
and they found five who were basically
infants premature they would have been
but they would have been able to survive
you know outside the womb and yet
washington dc
uh is treating that
just like we would treat the trash from
our lunch or something like that
it's really horrifying to see that that
could go on in our country but
particularly in our nation's capital and
so that is callous uh that is wrong and
i want to thank her and daley wire for
exposing that
so
great stuff i'm glad that uh governor
desantis recognized mary margaret olahan
who's doing really great journalistic
work it's nice that he mentioned daily
wire but the the law itself is just
great he's banning abortion after 15
weeks
really important stuff
there is a a good chance that roe versus
wade will be overturned in a matter of a
couple of months
this would be
the most important political development
i guess in my lifetime if you're talking
about now saving
hundreds of thousands of babies per year
at least
that would be great and so the states
are setting the stage one they set the
stage for the court challenge and then
two what happens
in a post roe vs wade world and desantis
is doing a great job on this one because
it's the right thing and i and i think
desantis has a really good political
compass
i and i think as far as politicians go
at least he does seem to have a good
moral compass
the other reason he's doing it is
because it's a political winner and
frankly this is even more important to
me because it means that there are now
real incentives for republican
politicians around the country to follow
this stuff
if you are a republican governor right
now and you have higher political
aspirations
pass one of these bills
do it not only is it the right thing to
do
but it is in your political interest
that is where the public opinion has
gone that is where the culture is moving
that is where the country's moving and
oh by the way it's the right thing to do
really really good stuff out of florida
what's the other side offering
for years the other side muddied the
waters on abortion by saying look we
don't support abortion we just think it
should be uh safe legal and rare
abortion is a really bad thing but
it should be legal for some reason why
why why is it a bad thing oh because it
murders babies well then if it murders
babies why should it be illegal they
never explained that but they used
enough squishy language that the old
clinton answer safe legal and rare that
that it muddied the waters that's not
the message of the left anymore the
message of the left is celebrate
abortion on demand without apology
there was a tweet that went viral from a
woman who was celebrating an abortion
she had just had
and the story looks legit to me
the woman took a picture of a cake the
cake said it's a boy and then over the y
she wrote orted
so it's aborted
and the woman wrote quote
abortion is healthcare and also
traumatic so if you do have one please
gather all of your closest friends after
to celebrate be around endless love and
happiness for your decision thanks to
everyone who came last night
two major problems here with what you
just said i i suspect given how sad and
desperate this this post is i actually
suspect this is real i don't think it's
a troll or a setup she says you got to
be around endless love and happiness
well
the only way you're going to get endless
love and happiness is
in the life of the world to come okay
you're only going to get that in
eternity in heaven here we live in a
finite world and in a finite world
eventually the party's over and
eventually the friends go home and
eventually the lights go out
and then what are you left with
if you are so desperate to manufacture
some artificial sense of celebration and
happiness
how long can you keep that up eventually
once the party's over what are you going
to be left with that same
nagging feeling that you were trying to
paper over with the balloons and the
streamers and the festivities and what
is that nagging feeling the nagging
feeling comes from what you say is a
traumatic event
that's my one question here lady
why is abortion traumatic
why is it dramatic
it's health care you say
it's a good thing
it's something to celebrate
so then why is it
traumatic well because
it's
a difficult decision
right why is it a difficult decision
well because it's a
look it's a complex issue sure okay
you're just asking you're just making
the same statement over and over again
why is it a complex issue because
it involves a mother killing her child
that's why that's where the trauma comes
from
we're not just talking about physical
trauma
we're talking about emotional trauma
here right that's why you've got to be
around the love and the happiness and
the festivities and everyone tell you
telling you you made the right decision
even though you didn't
so if it is traumatic if you know if
you're you're
being eaten away from the inside and you
just know it's so awful that you've got
to try to manufacture some semblance of
happiness
how about we just be honest and say you
shouldn't have done it in the first
place you're you're going to be a lot
happier if you just face up to that
if you have an abortion
that doesn't mean that your life is over
and you're condemned to hell and and
you'll never have a moment of happiness
or joy again you actually do have the
prospect of happiness and joy available
to you but you've got to be honest with
yourself about what you did
and you've got to repent you have to
change your mind that's what repentance
means means changing your mind you have
to turn your mind you have to turn the
way you're thinking about it and be
honest and if you're just going to live
in delusion and denial and
and beg all of your friends to come and
pretend that this horrible horrific act
is somehow other than it is you're
you're never going to be happy again
that's always going to be eating away at
you there's an abortion activist who
just made a similar kind of post
prominent abortion activist she said
quote
posted a picture of a book called what's
an abortion anyway it's a little
children's book and you've got a couple
of kids in the background her kids i
guess and she says this has been our
family's bedtime story on our vacation
this week as my niece loves this book
and reads it to her little sister every
night okay i guess it's her nieces our
family was created by abortion adoption
and parenting decisions
i love our family
and then she plugs the book
whatever else might be
true or sincere in this woman's
understanding of what happened
the one thing that i know for a fact was
a lie is that
she says our our family was created by
abortion no family is ever created by
abortion families are destroyed by
abortion that's all abortion can do
because abortion means killing
someone in your family right presumably
it's
the
the mother is the one who's getting the
abortion and so the abortion is
destroying your family it's so ghoulish
i mean the post itself is saying hey
kids
hey kids read this book and be happy i
didn't kill you be happy it was only
your siblings
ghoulish and we all know it's ghoulish
and this woman knows it's schoolish and
the lady doth protest too much me thinks
if
she or the cake lady if they were really
confident in their decision
if they were really secure and they felt
this really is the good thing they
wouldn't be lighting up a freaking cake
and they wouldn't be making these posts
and they wouldn't be writing books about
how great it was that they're now trying
to show to kids to convince the kids who
who obviously know better
and they wouldn't be posting it
constantly all the time i'm so good i
made the right decision i'm ready that
you can you can
read them gritting their teeth in the
posts
because they know
it's wrong
it's not you
the guilt that you feel for this
is not coming from me
i suspect neither of these ladies watch
my show or listen to my show or listen
to many other conservatives i suspect
they've probably ensconced themselves in
as much of a bubble as they possibly can
ideologically and i bet they just invite
all of their pro-abortion friends to
constantly affirm them in their bad
decision and yet they still know it's
wrong they are still
wracked by this nagging guilt that is
called your conscience
and you are not oh man you are not ever
going to feel better by trying to ignore
and suppress your conscience
by trying to deny
the shame and the guilt that you feel
shame and guilt are a healthy thing they
can be a healthy thing at least
because they're telling you you're going
down the wrong path
you can turn around the shame and the
guilt is not it's not the end of the
story but you
it it's it's like how we feel pain
right you it's good that we feel pain
it's good that we feel pain because we
know that we're in danger when i put my
hand on a hot stove i'm glad that i can
feel pain because i know get my hand
away do something different
same thing here with our moral
conscience
guilt
shame they can be very very good things
speaking of
guilt this is on a this is still regards
the leftists but it's on a completely
different issue
blm is in a lot of trouble and blm is in
a lot of trouble because blm which we
once believed stood for black lives
matter
actually it turns out stands for buy
large mansions
blm
raised
tens of millions of dollars i said for
something like 90 million dollars a
couple of years ago you know especially
at the height of the george floyd riots
and no one seems to be able to track
where all of that money went and when
the financial irregularities popped up
the leaders of the organization all
headed for the hills and now we find out
that blm spent upwards of six million
dollars on just one mansion in los
angeles and whenever we ask any
questions about it the co-founders of
blm say hey
that's
a triggering dangerous question
patrice cullers
who is one of the co-founders of blm
there were three co-founders all of them
avowed marxists
and but pretty clever political
operatives obviously they made a lot of
money
patrice cullers was just responding to a
question about the black lives matter
global network foundation which has come
under scrutiny now in particular for the
purchase of one mansion in los angeles
worth 5.8 million dollars
and she was asked hey what's going on
with your financial disclosures how come
you guys seem to have been hiding all
this stuff where are your 990 forms
right 990 forms the basic tax form that
nonprofit organizations have to have to
fill out and this woman
credit where credits do for the sheer
hutzpa for the sheer audacity of this
answer she says
it's such a trip to hear the term 990.
this is like
deeply unsafe
this is literally
being weaponized against us against the
people we work with
she says blm has been quote attacked and
scrutinized for the financial activities
quote people's morale in an organization
is so important
but if their organization and the people
in it are being attacked and scrutinized
and everything they do that leads to
deep burnout that leads to deep like
resistance and trauma
so
her argument is that
the irs
doing the same sort of analysis of blm
that it would do of any nonprofit
organization or any individual for that
matter
is
triggering
and unsafe
and it should not happen not only
should blm be permitted to burn the
country down with impunity
as they suggested in 2020
but blm also should be permitted
to launder money
and engage in all manner of financial
corruption without the irs looking into
it anything else would be racism
would be triggering would be violent
they're just saying hey we're a criminal
organization
and you better not look into us
that's an that's a nice political order
you got there sure would be a shame if
something happened to it this woman
makes al capone look like a boy scout
and you you gotta in a way you gotta
kind of respect the game at least she's
being open about it this is a woman
who's gone on camera and said yeah i'm a
marxist i want to completely upend
society yeah it's fine i'm not going to
make any apologies for blm burning the
country down or committing all sorts of
violence or threatening people or
embezzling money and funneling money
into all these crazy ways and enriching
myself i'm not going to apologize at all
what are you going to do about it take
the gun leave the cannoli we're out of
here
now you have to have a kind of grudging
respect for that brazenness for that
audacity are we going to do anything
about it this group blm is a criminal
organization there should be
ricoh cases against these guys this is
this is racketeering this these guys are
doing everything that the five families
did in new york except on a much larger
scale
are we going to do anything about that
are we going to investigate and
prosecute them
not as long as this ruling class is
allowed to maintain their power because
the ruling class the democratic party in
particular relies on blm to be its
militant wing it's the terrorist wing of
the political elite
speaking of crime a really strange story
out of a female prison
this is a women's only prison in new
jersey
where two of the female inmates
were just impregnated
by one of the other female inmates now i
like
a future supreme court justice katanji
jackson i am not a biologist
uh i suppose this could be miraculous or
there could be some development and by
or
oh right right that female inmate is not
really a female
she is a he it's a dude who's pretending
to be a woman
who has now just knocked up two of the
inmates
this occurs
less than a year after the state began
to adopt
this new transgender theory into the
prison system
which places inmates in the system
uh in based on their gender identity
rather than their actual sex
this story is going to be suppressed
because it
is just another example exposing the
transgender
uh
nonsense for what it is which is an
absurdity
this story apparently the the inmates
who were impregnated were impregnated
willingly
apparently that's not totally clear but
i think that's
generally what's being reported
but let's take it further
what is one of the main things that
occurs in prison
rape
rape it occurs so frequently in prison
that it's a joke
right the joke is hey you're going to
prison don't drop the soap hey you're
going to prison you better punch the
strongest guy in there because you're
going to be made somebody's girlfriend
you're going to be the girlfriend of
bubba when you go in there buddy right
this is a this is a joke in movies just
throughout our culture
and
it i guess it's bad enough when we're
talking about single sex prisons
but now let's say you've got hardened
criminal male criminals
going into female prisons
it's a little less funny isn't it it's a
little more
so it's a lot more jarring
well this could never happen they tell
us that you're just arguing about some
slippery slope now of course it's not
only is this stuff going to happen it is
happening now so what is your absurd
false gender ideology worth to you is it
worth lots of prisoners well one getting
knocked up that creates a huge problem
in and of itself think about these poor
kids these poor kids are now going to be
born to women in prison that's a
horrible situation for the women and for
the kids
or the kids are going to be killed
through abortion
or they're going to be sent into the
foster care system this is a horrible
situation
that was only that only exists now
because of the absurd selfish sexual
theories of radical degenerates who are
running our country
so that shouldn't happen period
what's it worth to you is it worth is
your radical crazy sexual theory worth
getting women raped
because that's what's happening
that's what's going to happen of course
we know actually that a transgender
bathroom policy in loudoun county led to
multiple rapes of young girls
we know that
is it worth that to you what the left
would say is yes
that's we know they would say that
because they know the risks and they're
pushing the stuff anyway can't make an
omelet without breaking a few eggs and
the omelet i guess is having men dress
up like women before we go i have to get
to the story before we get into the
mailbag new york times pushing this
gender bending weird stuff
this is from the style section of the
times
sexy lingerie for men is here
lacy thongs
and sheer undergarments designed for
men's bodies are shaking up the
traditional lingerie market
i'm no expert
but i don't think they are
i don't think so i don't think men are
going maybe
a very small
minority of homosexuals are doing this
a very small minority of an already very
small sexual minority maybe are doing
this kind of but this isn't really
happening the times is just trying to
make this happen the times like all of
our political institutions all of our
major
centers of power in the established
institutions
are trying to push this gender-bending
weird stuff that the vast majority of
americans don't want quit cramming it
down earth roads quit grooming the kids
and trying to trans the five-year-olds
and quit trying to get me to wear
lingerie i'm not doing it darn it
now as you know the daily wire is intent
on changing the culture which is why we
are actively
uh changing it in as many ways as we can
we're just we're we're doing it in books
we're doing it in movies we're doing it
and everything so we've got this
publishing winning dw books we're really
happy to publish books that are actively
fighting the left's monopoly on
storytelling such as fiery but mostly
peaceful the 2020 riots and the
gaslighting of america by julio rosas
who pulls back the curtains on the blm
riots that broke out across the country
and and burn city after city down rosas
exposes the media's attempts to convince
americans that the fatal riots the
destructive violent riots
were peaceful here's the trailer
the media guest looked the american
people for all of 2020 as the riots
unfolded they did not give you the full
story
i was there george floyd kyle
rittenhouse ray short books jazz in
seattle
i saw all the riots with my own eyes
windshields being smashed giant rocks
that were being thrown businesses that
were starting to be looted the crowd
started to become hostile
all the cops were trapped and surrounded
police were being ordered to to retreat
i experienced the tear gas i experienced
the smoke this was very real to me
the mainstream media they were trying to
call them protests cnn with that chiron
saying fiery but mostly peaceful they're
trying to push a narrative of don't
believe your lying eyes because they
were trying to appease a very dedicated
antifa movement that's there we read my
book fiery but mostly peaceful you will
get the full story you will learn what
actually happened during the riots of
2020 and what the media did not want to
tell you buy my book fiery but mostly
peaceful everywhere books are sold
looks great the book is available for
pre-order on amazon or anywhere you get
your books online so go pre-order your
copy today we will be right back
with the mailbag
welcome back to my absolute favorite
time of the week when i get to hear from
you in the mailbag
first question up is from sam dear
michael i'm in my 30s and a wife and
mother of two small children i'm doing
my best to live a wholesome life and
raise our children well but when i was
younger i had multiple abortions and all
i can say is that it destroyed my life
and any semblance of self-respect i may
have once had my feelings about it get
worse and worse as i get older and the
thought of what i participated in makes
me almost physically ill there were even
times over the years that i felt
suicidal i still struggle with the
feeling that i do not deserve to be
alive and don't deserve my beautiful
children i now have i cannot change the
past but it is consuming me and i want
to be a strong and happy person for my
kids how in the world can i move beyond
these disastrous feelings and stop
hating myself
i'm going to give you a specific
religious answer that i think will help
you a lot
i don't know your religious views or
what church you're a part of i would
just
strongly recommend and i say this from
my experience as a catholic you should
go to confession and receive absolution
that's my very practical
advice now i'll broaden that out a
little bit
philosophically and historically
saint paul
was a murderer
saint paul
who is
one of the most important men to ever
walk the earth one of the greatest
evangelists in history wrote a lot of
the new testament saint paul
was present at sort of participated in
the martyrdom of saint stephen the first
christian martyr he was there the the
people who were throwing the rocks at
saint stephen put their coats by saint
paul to watch their clothing
okay this guy was
a really tough persecutor of christians
and then
he had his conversion on the road to
damascus and he turned his life around
and then he became one of the greatest
men in history you can't change the past
you can change what you're doing now and
what you're doing in the future it
sounds like you've already done that
if if grappling with what you did and
i'm not going to sugarcoat it what you
did is just terrible but
one perspective that i have gained from
christianity that is has really
changed the way i view the world is that
christians are in one sense the most
judgmental people on earth because they
have an answer for everything because
they have a very cogent coherent
understanding of the moral order of
actions that seem small and trivial and
actions that seem very large and public
but on the other hand at the same time
paradoxically christians are the least
judgmental people on earth because all
sin and falls short of the glory of god
and and i know that when i have lust in
my heart that i'm i'm committing
adultery when i'm angry at my brother
i'm committing murder
we know that we're
not perfect and we sin all the time
and so the great hope there is that you
there is the opportunity for repentance
and forgiveness and absolution of your
sins and that's not just soft soap and
wishful thinking that's
that's a fact
if you're a christian that is that
that's a you are basing that on an
historical event called the crucifixion
and the resurrection
funny coincidental providential perhaps
that you're asking me this question on
good friday which is when we
when we commemorate the crucifixion
where christ conquers death on the cross
and is resurrected and and those who
believe in christ and follow him can
have eternal life and be forgiven their
sins
so that's that's my answer for you i
know that some people out there who are
more secular or who they want me to give
some kind of atheist rationalist answer
for that i can't
i can't do that if we lived in a
if we lived in a world that really was
atheistic where
then i couldn't i couldn't give you an
answer to how to feel better that made
any sense actually nothing would make
sense at all there would be there would
be there would be no logic to the
universe
but luckily
that's not the atheist delusion isn't
real so
there there is there is an actual real
hard fact of repentance and atonement
and and some of the
worst people who have committed the
worst crimes in the world have have
become some of the holiest people on
earth
since john vianney said the saints did
not all start well but they all ended
well
and you can too and the way to do that
is not to deny or suppress or try to put
out of your mind what you did but to
grapple with it head on
from carrie hey michael i'm a 17 year
old girl my best friend of nine years is
an 18 year old boy we have never had any
interest in dating each other the
thought isn't even in the realm of
possibility recently my friend has
started to date a girl i don't know i'm
very happy for him but i'm worried not
only did he tell me very suddenly one
day but he has since started talking to
me significantly less the girl said she
felt uncomfortable by how good friends
he and i are when we met at prom i knew
stuff like this could happen when we
date other people since we are not the
same sex but i feel so unprepared to
lose touch with my best friend any
advice is welcome and desperately needed
sincerely too worried to say something
witty
sorry carrie
that's the way it goes
that's the way it goes you have to ask
yourself
one question first when you say he and i
would never even consider dating each
other that's that's nuts we would never
do that do you really mean that or is
that just a thing you say because you
met with a very young age and you hadn't
made sense of
sexual attraction yet and so now you're
just so used to doing that you don't
want to risk a great friendship to
possibly date him because that that
happens sometimes too and if that's the
case you and he should actually date
but if that's not the case and you
actually
don't have any sexual attraction to one
another then you're just gonna have to
deal with the fact that
you and he are not going to be as good
friends moving into the future
because
men and women are different and because
when guys start dating other girls and
certainly when they get married
their friendships
with women and especially with single
women
just
don't work as well
because it's weird it's we it's the mike
pence rule it's weird for a married man
to have to go on dates with women it's
just weird you're really not supposed to
do that doesn't mean that you can't have
any friendship moving into the future
uh even in the current circumstances
certainly while he's dating dating
people and before he's married
but one one way that this could could
work is he's got some girlfriend and you
guys are hanging out maybe you get some
boyfriend and then all four of you hang
out that would be a way to
spend time together that would be that
would be a little more
wholesome and less open to the prospect
of you and he you know having a few too
many cocktails one night and whatever
happens happens oh i never expected it
and then then maybe it does because that
sexual difference really does matter
that actually is a powerful force that
you can't merely deny just because you
you've been friends for a long time
that's one thing maybe you become
friends with his girlfriend i don't know
or maybe she's
a jerk and you don't like her very much
and you want him to dump her and get
some better girlfriend or date you
instead but
uh there's no there's not going to be
any sugarcoating it
that's that is inevitably what happens
to friendships between men and women
that are platonic and not sexual at all
uh because we're gonna
we're gonna grow closer to our
boyfriends and girlfriends and then
ultimately to our spouse and if you want
to maintain that i have lots of female
friends so and many of whom i've been
friends with for many many years but if
you want to maintain those friendships
they're going to have to evolve and
change it's not not just going to be you
and him
anymore it's going to involve other
people because if it's just you and him
then you know date and get married from
mitch hey michael i know the rest of the
hosts at dw don't want to hear this but
you have the most style stop it get out
of here come on why would you what would
you say something like that
so where
did you get your impeccable taste
thank you for that
flattering question
i got it from
elvis presley
i've been an elvis fan since i was five
years old
frank sinatra same thing i've been a
sinatra fan since i was five or six
years old and uh
j press
or so you know the kind of more waspy
american old school style those are the
preppy kind of those those would be the
three places
you get the kind of slick
slick stuff from the mid-century
uh italians and showbiz and then a
little more put together from that that
nice preppy style it's that it never
goes out of style that's that's a great
thing about
all of that from daniel dear michael i
have heard you say several times that
moderation is a virtue i have struggled
with moderation when it comes to
drinking alcohol at times i know many
people struggle with socially acceptable
vices such as food caffeine tobacco or
the aforementioned alcohol could you
please expound upon the idea of
moderation as a virtue as a christian do
you have any wisdom on accepting grace
for god for falling short
versus getting upset with myself for
lack of moderation i've become more
temperate as i've gotten older but i
think that if i gained some insight i
could enjoy some of life's pleasures
without some of the regrets p.s
listening to your show every morning and
uh
and you turned me onto cigars i love
them and thankfully have only
overindulged a couple of times oh that's
great i'm glad to hear it i do fear
though that i've i've turned so many of
my friends onto cigars at this point
that statistically i've probably killed
a few of them i hope not i hope not i
hope you know they everyone has in
moderation and we avoid the dangers of
that but um
glad to hear glad to hear that and look
what you're describing is something
that's really common
i don't
i don't know very many people who have
not over indulged in booze
in their younger years late teens early
to mid-20s i mean that sort of thing
happens i i certainly drank way more
when i was in college and in my early
20s than i do now now i don't really
have time to drink because i have a
screaming baby who
i have to attend to so
that happens but but really
you should pursue moderation even in
drinking which is so socially acceptable
because
it's the right thing to do intrinsically
and you're going to feel terrible the
next day when you drink too much
during the night then you're just
borrowing happiness from the next day
because the next day you're going to
wake up and you're going to have a
terrible headache
and you're going to do things that you
don't want to do and you're going to say
things that you don't want to say and
it's just not a good look and you're
going to regret it so
if
i don't have a particularly addictive
personality so it's i know people who
are addicts who have extremely addictive
personalities for it is it is never hard
for me to say okay i can't have any more
booze okay i'll put this down
it's never hard for me even you know how
much i love cigars for me to say okay i
can't smoke cigars this week okay no big
deal
that's so for me it's i'm not i'm not
really worried about it but i do know
people who if they have one drink they
need to have 10 drinks and there is no
middle ground there's no two or three
drinks for them and so for those people
you might have to abstain you might just
have to say okay if one means 10 then
i'm just going to abstain if if one
cigar means i'm going to start smoking
two packs of cigarettes a day and i
can't stop then you just can't smoke
cigars and that's too bad and maybe it's
because of your genes and maybe it's
because of your experiences but
that's too bad for you
and it seems unfair i think nor
mcdonald's made this point he says it
seems really unfair
that uh
alcoholics who really really like booze
can't have any booze and i who i'm not
an alcoholic and i don't really like
booze that much i'm allowed to have as
much booze as i want yeah that's true
it's unfair but
that is sort of the point of moderation
is it it is a little bit contingent on
you and and your tastes and your
discipline and your abilities so if it's
just that you know you're in your early
20s and you're drinking a little too
much
maybe you don't need to worry about that
but if if you're finding that it's a
real problem you might just have to
abstain from peter hey michael i was
hoping you could clear this up for me
uh you told ethan bearman if sexual
ideology is not being taught then why
would you oppose the parental rights
education bill because if it's not
happening then this
doesn't change anything and it shouldn't
be an issue but couldn't the left use
that same argument against us with
regard to the anti-lynching bill if
lynching isn't happening then why are
you voting against the bill to me the
statement made to ethan berman is better
left unsaid because it can be used to
undermine the reason for voting against
the anti-lynching bill and instead we
should focus on the fact that sexuality
sexual ideology is actually being taught
which is what makes the bill necessary
thoughts thanks and love the show well
it's that's a good question and your
point is almost totally right but
there's another difference here which is
the anti-lynching bill
that just came up that the democrats
only passed to
portray republicans as as pro-lynching
or to pretend that lynching is still a
problem in america and that's why we
need all of this anti-racist
activism
lynching is already illegal not only is
lynching not happening
and no lynching has happened for many
decades in america and that was only one
and before that really the last time
that lynching was anything even near
a
frequent problem in america was in the
40s and 50s
but it's already illegal it's already
illegal to murder people
it's that there are federal laws against
murder there's state laws against murder
and so the anti-lynching bill there are
laws against hate crimes as opposed to
what love crimes and so it's it's
already illegal in many ways so there's
no reason to add that whereas right now
until this law was passed in florida it
was not illegal
to teach kids about sex so even beyond
the question of is this actually
happening is another question is this
legal or illegal
in the case of lynching it was already
illegal so why pass a law to outlaw a
thing that's already illegal whereas in
florida
whether it's happening or not it was not
illegal and so that law is clarifying it
so i don't think they're they're
comparable and i think it's why it's
important to
to point out the hypocrisy of the lives
here or the contradictory stories this
isn't being taught in schools and it's a
good thing that it is i think you can
point that out with any risk of
hypocrisy for conservatives all right
that's our show i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show have a happy
easter we'll see you on monday
[Music]
if you enjoyed this episode don't forget
to subscribe and if you want to help
spread the word please give us a five
star review and tell your friends to
subscribe we're available on apple
podcasts spotify and wherever else you
listen to podcasts also be sure to check
out the other daily wire podcasts
including the ben shapiro show the
andrew clavin show and the matte wall
show the michael knowles show is
produced by ben davies executive
producer jeremy boring supervising
producer mathis glover production
manager pavel vadovsky editor and
associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 22. hey everybody this is
andrew clavin host of the andrew clavin
show you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood but on the andrew clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me andrew
clavin